mark Morgan knows a lot about this
subject he ran Customs and Border Patrol
under the previous President President
Obama and he joins this time mr. Morgan
thank you very much for coming on so
Democrats are demanding that icecap bed
space and the interior of the country
not the borders in the center of the
country to 16,500 year if that were to
happen what would it mean so what that
is is that's a significant step towards
really abolishing ice via the checkbook
and there's actually two elements to
their plan they want to actually reduce
overall bed space for ice and then cap
the interior enforcement so basically
you know we already know that if you're
a child or our family unit you get
you're gonna be allowed in this country
thatthat sketch or at least 1.0 this
will virtually mean catch release 2.0
common sense right as bed space goes
down illegal immigration goes up ice
Border Patrol turns everybody we
apprehend over to ice as the bed space
goes down that means they're gonna have
to release more individuals into the
interior United States that is catch or
at least 2.0 the other thing real quick
what that does is from a common-sense
standpoint that means that that people
here they're here illegally and have
committed an additional crime and/or
charge of additional crime ice will be
forced to release them so the argument
you hear from Democrats is these people
shouldn't have been arrested in the
first place the overwhelming majority of
people arrested by ice have done nothing
wrong other than adding to our economy
and that it's bigoted to arrest them one
of the numbers tell us about it
completely false and that's that's the
question so right now ice alone last
year arrested I think the number is well
in excess of a hundred and twenty
thousand individuals they're here
illegally for an additional crime right
now the forty five thousand that ice has
detained right now it's seventy to
eighty percent of them almost I think
around eighty five percent of them have
been convicted and or charged with
another crime besides enter and
illegally so that's a complete false
narrative I think the number is eighty
eight percent so that would mean just to
be completely clear as a math question
if you capped bed space at the threshold
they're calling for by definition you'd
be releasing criminals into the
population that's correct right now if
you do the math immediately if this if
this bill passed they
have to probably release about 8,000
individuals criminal aliens and it's not
the crime of illegally entering this is
crimes in addition to that so what
percentage of those show back up for
their hearings would you say none the
numbers three percent we've checked and
I think those people wandered in by
accident so basically you're suspending
the rule of law for a large group of
people who've been charged with or
convicted of crime that's right you're
reducing the bed space illegal
immigration is increasing the numbers
will show that and and so more people
are going to be released into the
interior United States and they're
telling ice they can't enforce that and
actually go and get them what we've
created here is a sanctuary country
that's where we're headed so is there
any sheriffs organization border patrol
organization law enforcement
organization that supports this idea I
don't know of one do you so where did
this come from and what's the point of
it I mean so it would be the goal of
this the goal and this has been tough
for me to get to and and I don't say
this is but this is pure identity
politics
I can draw no other conclusion from this
last minute stunt that is it's insane
Tucker so it's got to be driven by a
identity politics and I really think the
ultimate goal is open borders it seems
that way mr. Morgan thank you very much
for that Thank You Tucker